[Music]
what's popping miss evans on the beat so
tapping
you got options but you better pass my
class no flopping that green
that gold tornado left let
go yes
[Music]
they are the georgia teachers going
viral for the way that they're welcoming
students back during
this virus i have mrs williams
mrs evans what's poppin
what's what's happening how are you
enjoying your life right now
well i am truly enjoying it um
i can't believe all of the love and all
of the support that we're getting
for something that we just do every year
for fun to make ourselves feel good and
to make the students feel good
even while i'm teaching with my students
today because we still had school
as soon as they got on the zoom car they
were like miss miss evans we
we saw you and miss williams so we
should tell people that the school year
has already started like you said you've
been in class today
so how are you handling all the
attention you said the minute you get
onto the zoom your students are like
miss williams
miss evans what's poppin
farts is teaching go i am unreachable
i'm number one on your top 10
miss williams been popping to the new
school you're dropping
yeah it was kind of crazy because as
soon as i start virtual teaching they
log into class that's the first thing
that they are mentioning i tried to
incorporate what we did
in the class time they were already
talking about it was already buzzing so
i said let's go ahead and make this an
assignment so
they had to create a wrap for my class
which i teach economics
and they had to come up with eight lines
i gave them the instrumental
it was just really good to be able to
see my students get creative
and just uh spit those bars bars on
bars i teach a class with this drip part
go ahead take a picture on your iphone
virtual and you know miss williams how
did the idea come about
i'm probably on tick tock 24 7. that's
probably the app that i just watched all
day
um and you can really see what song is
popping by watching tick tock one of
them was what's popping so when i'm
listening to the beat
i'm like oh yeah yeah i got to put a
wrap on this so
i brought what's popping to miss evans
and
and that was it being that we were
teachers it already helps to know
how to um the diction in our voice the
words that the kids are going to
like we were able to write and come up
with our verse
and then we practiced in front of each
other so we practiced for probably like
two or three days
and we would tell each other yeah i like
that no you need to take that out or you
need to do this
you need to do that and then after that
we went in the studio
and then that's where all the magic
happened number 19 had a stress but it's
nothing we gonna overcome that fact no
bluffing why your mouth wash your hands
people say this is cause i really
thought that a pain
so you guys you come up with the idea
right
you shoot the video which in itself was
a music video
i am period
okay what did you hope would happen the
only
outcome that we wanted to get out of
this was to really get the kids
excited about going back to school
virtually especially with everything
going on with copenhagen
um a lot of things that were misplaced
families being lost just to bring some
excitement back into everyone's life and
even the teachers lives because we're
teachers
we were nervous about how the school
year would be what's been the best part
of this experience
honestly the best part for me um is
actually doing this journey with mrs
evans i think it is really an amazing
feeling to not only do something by
yourself
and watch um your videos go viral but to
know that your friend
is blowing up as well with you so that's
probably the thing that i love most
about this journey is that my friend
slash sister is on this drive
on this ride with me yes i'm sorry
i did not expect to be crying but i was
literally going to say the same thing
it's super unreal that i get to share
this with somebody that i've known for
so long
i mean i wouldn't want to share with
anyone else so what is your message
for for students for teachers for people
who are struggling with this moment
who want to bring their best selves just
like you have in this moment
but don't even know where to start in
some cases
having a really hard time my advice
would be
to um you can overcome any adversity
um in our city we have a lot of
poverty um we're a title one school so
we have students that do not have a lot
no matter your environment you can still
be great you can still
make it to the top no cap okay
and that's on period
no flopping no stopping
we mopping yeah made a way made away
made away another way another way you
know miss
evans don't play yeah